okay hi there welcome to another episode
of science and technology
uh history of science and technology q a
um
this is on a different day than usual my
apologies for switching things around
this is a time of year where we're in
the middle of our our
summer educational programs and um
i keep on getting pulled into things
related to that
in fact we'll be live streaming a few of
the events probably from our summer
school we have
um uh well three or four depending on
how you count it different programs all
running right now this week we have a
middle school summer camp uh next week
we have
a week zero of our summer school
that is the pre-week for the physics
track of our summer school
then we have three weeks of our summer
school and in the last two weeks of that
three week period
we also have our high school summer camp
um
so anyway lots of lots of educational
programs uh
the middle school one is a little easier
for me because we are not
assigning individual projects to
everybody and that's
part of my responsibility for our summer
school and high school summer camp
um so that's kind of my moment of
extreme professoring in the year
when um we'll have i don't know 100
i don't know 100 and something students
and um
uh the the goal and the thing we always
achieve is to come up with
unique original projects for each
student
and um i typically make a list of
potential projects and people pick
partly from that list and partly from
things they want to do and then
i'm kind of responsible for for the
final selection there
anyway lots of fun for me but uh also
rather an intense period with
rather tight scheduling so um these
uh these live streams might bounce
around a bit but there may be some
interesting
uh unique um uh additional live streams
which we'll be doing
as part of particularly the summer
school all right
so let's see there were all kinds of
questions
left over here um there's one from
mikhail about how was dna discovered
history behind its discovery not sure i
can tell you all of the details there
um a few of the characters involved i i
do know
somewhat i mean uh jim watson is still
alive i've certainly met a number of
times
and francis crick i knew somewhat um
uh those were the sort of two uh most
credited people
and i guess some uh
jim watson wrote this book called the
double helix which is kind of a
adventure story book about the discovery
of of dna
in 1953 i think its first sentence is i
have never seen francis
crick in a modest mood or some such
other thing
i'm not sure that that would quite be
the way that i would uh
describe at least my interactions with
francis crick but of course i knew him
much later in his life
um there's a little bit of the science
of what was going on i mean before
people knew
that there was dna in the cell nucleus
and that had been known for a long time
i think
um uh people um
back from the 1920s 1930s had known that
um
i don't know how much thomas hunt morgan
who was a big sort of fruit fly genetics
person i don't know exactly how much he
knew i think
i think he knew things about the
molecular what kinds of
uh of substances were involved in the
cell nucleus
but just how heredity worked wasn't i
mean it was
certain laws of heredity were known
they'd been they've been figured out by
gregor mendel
and other people um had figured out
these you know heritable traits and
these different kinds of um
dominant recessive traits all this kind
of thing but the mechanism by which that
worked
was not clear and there was this sort of
idea of of genes and so on which were
all a bit kind of based on the
observation of what effects they had
rather than the mechanism by which they
were made and so
so there was dna it was in the cell
nucleus
it probably had something to do with
heredity but it wasn't really known how
that worked
and there had been some vague thinking i
think that it might be something that
was a little bit like
kind of uh storing
data or something but the idea of
storing data wasn't yet a big thing
because remember
the uh you know historically 1953 which
was sort of the big year for the
figuring out of how dna works um that
was
something that um uh was
in the very early days of computers i
mean today when you say
there's information there's data it's
stored digitally everybody would know
what that meant because everybody is
used to kind of the
the world of computers but that simply
didn't exist in those days the
the typical let's say physicist or
something would never have seen a
computer the typical biologist would
never have seen a computer
i suppose there was a um
uh you know so that so this idea that
there would be this sort of digital
information thing
wasn't really a thing yet i'm i'm i'm
kind of thinking that
um and i may have my history slightly
mixed up there's a physicist named
george gamoff
who um was also much involved in the
origination of the big bang model of the
early universe and so on
um who uh maybe it was after
the actual main discovery of dna but he
was involved in later in figuring out
the code by which you go from base pairs
to proteins
uh to amino acids to proteins and so on
but i think there have been some
suggestions that maybe
there was some sort of digital
information component to dna
okay but then the real question was
there's this molecule
what's the structure of the molecule so
a few other molecules
biological molecules their structure had
been figured out
normally you know how do you figure out
the structure of a molecule
well the big method that was used was
x-ray crystallography
so the the thing to understand is in a
crystal
the atoms are arranged in a very regular
periodic way
the question is in what way are they
arranged you know you have a diamond
crystal you have a salt crystal
the atoms are arranged differently in a
salt crystal it's a um
a cubic arrangement of atoms
in a diamond crystal well it's usually
called the diameter range but i guess
it's a hexagonal
ish arrangement of of atoms and the
question is what is the arrangement of
atoms
and there's this technique called x-ray
crystallography which is a way given
that you have a crystal
it's a way of saying what is the
arrangement of atoms in the crystal
and it works by by reflecting x-rays
from the crystal
and when the x-rays are reflected
specifically from the atoms on the
crystal and depending on how the atoms
are lined up
you get lines of destructive or not or
constructive interference
between the emission of uh the the
re-emission of x-rays from the surface
it's actually
very much like the way that a phased
array uh
uh radio works when in in 5g
for example one has this whole idea of
oh
one will emit radio from this sort of
distributed antenna
and it will be all directed in a certain
direction because the phases of the
different
things coming from those different parts
of the antenna will be
arranged so that the the um radio energy
goes in a particular direction
it's sort of the same kind of idea with
x-ray crystallography
except that there there's sort of a
natural array
that is made up by the the atoms and the
crystal lattice
and so that's kind of the way that one
uh tries to figure out
how um uh um
you know how the how something how a
molecule
is arranged how the atoms in a molecule
arrange
is well if you can make a crystal of
that molecule
with that molecule then everything is
lined up many many copies of it are
lined up and then you can use x-ray
crystallography
to try and find the arrangement of atoms
now one of the big challenges there is
how to actually do the crystallization
how to take this material and have it
form into a big crystal
and that's a very tricky thing in the
the the sort of theory of
crystallization
is still quite incomplete and it's still
kind of often a
something of a mysterious art to make a
big perfect crystal
to something very important in the
manufacture in semiconductor
manufacturing
um making these big crystals big as
perfect as possible crystals of silicone
but back in the day people were making
um
uh crystals of some of these um
biological molecules i think hemoglobin
was an early one i think myoglobin was
another one
i seem to remember the chap who was um i
think it was a person called john
kendrew
who was um the uh um
uh the person who declared i think
myoglobin
by crystallizing it and then using x-ray
crystallography strangely enough in the
in the weird connections of this world
he was an alumnus of the elementary
school that i went to
in in oxford england and i remember
there was a a um
a sort of a grand sort of uh
science exhibition opening thing when i
was like eight years old
that this uh then very ancient seeming
person
uh showed up to and i i you know at
least said hello so to speak
i don't know uh uh that was the um sort
of the
that shows the the difference in in
timing so that was the you know by
that will have been 1968 or so um the
person who had sort of decoded myoglobin
was by that point an old older person
um the in any case the big challenge in
all these things was
how do you make how do you crystallize
these these complicated molecules
because
if it's a complicated molecule it's
flapping around all over the place
it's not easy to make sure that it can
sort of line itself up perfectly
um but that was some uh
it was kind of a big challenge i don't
know the full history of this i think
rosalind franklin in london
was um the person who was most deeply
involved in kind of the
the crystallization and x-ray
crystallography of dna
but the question was when you do x-ray
crystallography
what you get is a bunch of bright and
bright spots
from what were the angles at which the
x-rays were
um were kind of um emitted from
uh from the crystal and then the
question is
that gives you essentially a fourier
transform of
the actual distribution of atoms in
other words what it's telling you
is if you look at a sort of if there was
a periodic array of atoms
with a definite period that would be
like a wave of a definite frequency and
that would be like a single spot
but what you're seeing is what
arrangement of different periodicities
of atoms are there
going in different directions and that's
the arrangement of spots that you get
and so there's then a big decoding
problem if you've got this arrangement
of spots
now there's sort of the puzzle of well
what's the actual arrangement of atoms
that gives that particular arrangement
of spots
and in general it's not unique in
general for any arrangement of spots
and technically it's because you only
have the intensity you don't have the
phase information of the x-rays you only
have the intensity of the spot in a
certain at certain angle
but the question is given the intensity
of spots given this distribution of
spots
what is the actual structure of the
molecule that produces that and as i say
it's not unique so there could be many
different shapes of molecules that could
produce the same distribution of spots
of course many of those shapes of
molecules would not be plausibly
constructable out of atoms
and so then there's this kind of almost
mathematical problem of can you kind of
reverse engineer the thing to figure out
what structure
would lead to this uh pattern of
x-ray crystallography output and i think
the dynamics of what happened is i think
rosalind franklin was the person who
got the x-ray crystallography done and i
think
then uh jim watson and francis crick
were the people
they were working in cambridge england
they were the people who figured out
kind of what would be the distribution
of atoms that would lead to that x-ray
crystallography pattern
and they famous they had this thing made
out of meccano that was kind of this
uh helical structure that was the thing
that they figured out would lead to that
pattern of of spots
and so that was sort of the big thing
was figuring out that structure
and then the question was well so what
does how does that structure actually
work what does it do
and that took a number more years and i
think in the original paper
that they wrote in nature magazine in
1953 they had sort of a couple of
sentences at the end saying
you know this might suggest that perhaps
there's a whole
sort of digital information story
associated with dna which i think kind
of implies that they weren't the ones
who originated that
digital information story but nobody
could kind of see how to make it work
before it was known what the structure
of the dna molecule was
now i think the it's sort of interesting
to see the
kind of uh career tracks i think i think
francis crick had been
doing physics um before kind of going
into this
sort of biology direction i mean in his
later life
he kind of changed direction and worked
on things about the brain
and neuroscience and consciousness and
so on
um and uh i met him when he was in that
sort of phase of life
um jim watson continued very much in the
um
molecular biology uh was a co-author of
a sort of standard textbook
was very much involved with cold spring
harbor
which is kind of a well it's a place
with a very unfortunate history that
goes back to the
the world of eugenics in the early 1900s
in the u.s
but is a distinguished place where a lot
of important research
in molecular biology has been done um
and uh he was also involved jim watson
was also involved in kind of the
pushing for a government-sponsored uh
human genome project and so on
um he's also a person who
i would say believes that
perhaps his
the things that he can deduce about the
world from science
are definitively the way the world has
to be and sometimes i think perhaps uh
uh downgrades uh sort of other
views about the world and comes to all
kinds of conclusions that he says look
it's scientifically provable that this
this is true
but actually sort of missing a big piece
of of the picture but that's kind of his
subsequent life i mean the the uh
the thing for which he is best known is
the 1953 discovery of the structure of
dna
so that's kind of the um uh um the story
there um and
of course it took a number of years it
wasn't
you know well i see the history from
from far after it happened
but by the 1960s things were really
hopping in terms of the development of
molecular biology
as a field molecular biology kind of
started popping up as departments and
universities only considerably later
70s 80s and so on but as something where
people were sort of figuring out the key
ideas
figuring out messenger rna transfer rna
how that whole
sort of mechanism worked that was really
a story of the 1960s centered around
places like cambridge and cold spring
harbor and places like that
um and i i guess jim watson was at um
uh at harvard for a while so it was it
was kind of
the two cambridges and and other places
um i think
one person who was a uh a uh figure in
that whole thing was pleasant called
sydney brenner who i knew reasonably
well
who was for example the discoverer of
messenger rna
which is of course famous now because
it's been used in a couple of these
vaccines the pfizer and madonna vaccines
use that
one of the things sort of interesting
about him was you know he had been
trained as a biologist but he had a deep
interest in computation
and sort of computational kinds of
things from
right when he was he grew up in south
africa right when he was sort of first
going through school and uh famously
he had uh you know written letters to
alan turing
when uh in the 1950s
when alan turing was sort of thinking
about biological kinds of things
but sydney brenner was definitely
somebody who
sort of thought about biology in
computational terms
and he encouraged me for many years to
uh you know to take all the stuff that i
figured out about computation how it
works
and apply it to biology finally maybe i
have some ideas about how to
take the next step in in doing that
application
but um the main thing is that for sydney
brenner
it was kind of thinking about the
mechanisms of biology computationally
was sort of what came first it wasn't
like let me go and understand these
molecules and then deduce that they are
computational
for him it was very much i think that he
was
thinking in computational terms and
trying to fit
sort of these mechanisms that he was
thinking about computationally
into what biological organisms and
biological systems actually do
anyway so a little bit on discovery of
dna
let's see um
[Music]
boy there's a question here about from a
tory about history of
musical digital instruments like synths
and computational music and so on um
well you guys are you guys are really
testing my memory
here my gosh i should uh see i'm i'm um
this is uh so let me let me tell you a
few things that i know about
about that i mean the
sort of the idea of
non-standard musical instruments was
something that i think in the early
1900s was
as as sort of electricity became a more
common and popular thing
people are like how can you apply
electricity-like ideas to the generation
of music
and so for example there's this
instrument called a theremin
that was sort of an early electrically
uh inspired and developed
instrument and i think people like
nikola tesla were involved in sort of
like things and and making the kind of
noises that that theremins make
um i think that the the for a while
these were sort of analog
uh processes where you're just using you
know inductors capacitors resistors
and electrical systems and i think to
some extent i think i think in those
systems you actually sort of like put
your hands in the electric field
and you are uh you are distorting the
the field lines of the electric field by
where you put your hands and that's kind
of
how you play the instrument and that
what you're doing is you're essentially
dealing with
an electric circuit you can have between
an inductor
loop of wire and a capacitor something
that's storing charge
um you can make with with an electron a
capacitor
you can make an oscillator and
essentially what you're doing
in something like a theremin is you're
changing the characteristics of the
inductor and capacitor
by you know moving your hands around or
moving other elements around
um and that is changing the frequency of
the oscillator
and so that will in in in a a
sort of a a standard note on a musical
instrument
has a fundamental frequency that is a a
definite
you know frequency let's say it's middle
c it might be roughly 256
uh cycles per second um and that means
it's a
sine wave of of sound pressure um at
least that's the fundamental part of the
note
on a piano there'll be a whole sort of
structure of overtones to that note
uh double the frequency etc etc etc and
other
sort of things that are around that are
that have that as the base frequency but
then there's a whole
elaborate collection of other
frequencies that are also involved
that give the kind of the color the
timbre of the note
that's being produced so it isn't just a
a pure
uh annoying sort of pure tone but gives
sort of a
a a a depth to the to the sounds
but so the early thing i think 1920s and
1930s
it was pretty common to see these sort
of electrically based instruments
that were essentially tweaking the idea
of an inductor capacitor oscillator type
circuit
um the um i think
the early kind of more portable
sort of synthesizer instruments i think
uh was
his name robert moog maybe of the moog
synthesizer company and device
um i think
uh and now you're i think that is still
an analog device
um so still something where you actually
have circuit elements and you're
changing capacitances and things like
that
the big moment of digital
producing digital uh so the real
question is it's easy to make a piece of
electronics
that will make a tone of a fixed
frequency
and you can have an oscillator
in um in digital electronics you will
typically have
oscillators that drive the clock that is
specifying you know
what which instruction the sequence of
instructions you use and so on
but um uh the to get a pure tone
a single sine wave is something you
rather easily get from an oscillator
um and the the big question is how do
you get kind of a realistic
sounding you know piano trumpet whatever
else kind of sound how do you synthesize
that sound
and so the the first
big kind of innovation in that area was
a thing called fm synthesis
and that was in the early 1970s i think
developed particularly around stanford
and i am
forgetting the name of the chap who i
have certainly met
who um who did that but um
the idea there is usually
you have a sign a pure tone is a sine
wave so it's sine
two pi frequency times time and
uh that's the the the
amplitude of the sound wave the pressure
in the in the air
is you know basically uh
omega times that the frequency times
time
in a sine of the frequency times time
okay
so the idea of fm synthesis is
that inside that sine function is
another sine
function so you're you're kind of
changing the frequency
as a function of time and that trick
turns out with the different parameters
for that
uh frequency changing inside the inside
the sine function
that trick ends up giving you uh
lots of different kinds of structures of
notes and so on
where you can get a reasonable
approximation to
uh to a variety of musical instruments
not perfect but it's a first
approximation
and the sort of first generation of kind
of
easy electronic synthesizers
particularly coming out of companies in
japan
um was was very much based on this fm
synthesis idea
now subsequently the when it comes to
emulating
actual musical instruments this notion
of sound fonts
has come in where basically every note
it's like you you're saying play an a
well it's like if you say print an a you
say well i'm going to print this a but
i'm going to print it with this
particular nice nicely drawn font
well similarly when you make an a as a
sound
it's like render that a using the
particular
sort of structure of of uh
amplitude as a function of time the
particular waveform
that it corresponds to this sound font
and so you might get that sound font by
recording somebody actually playing a
piano
sampling the sound from somebody
actually playing an a on a piano
and you say that's the sound font that
we're going to use that's the
the a character well it's actually a
sound in the sound font that we're going
to use for the
for the for the note a things get more
tricky because
the attack the kind of how the note is
pressed
and sort of how the intensity of the
sound ramps up
in the very early moments as the note is
being played that's important to how we
perceive the note how the decay works
and so on
so it's a little bit trickier and
there's there's all kinds of
detailed technology and tricks to make
that sound good but that's been the more
modern way
to produce kind of sounds now in terms
of
electronic music the there's sort of the
question of the
the rendering of the music the kinds of
notes that can get made
the kinds of effects you can get from
sort of electronic circuits
uh there's been not so much done
on sort of architecting the structure of
the note
by algorithms there's some things done
but it's not been
as uh as extensive as one might think
it's not been the case
you know i know from playing around with
with our language and mathematica
uh we had put in the ability to play an
arbitrary waveform
back in like 1990 and you could do
sort of fm synthesis very easily and you
could start experimenting with different
kinds of functions and saying what do
these sound like
do they sound interesting is that like a
new musical instrument that you can
discover
see one feature of musical instruments
is they have a habit of very much being
based on notes
it's you know c d e f whatever
definite uh notes where there's a
definite
sort of uh dominant frequency and
you know when it's a string the reason
there's that dominant frequency is the
string is vibrating
and it has a certain there's a certain
mode of the string the string has
certain lengths
and that means that there's a certain
dominant frequency associated with its
lowest mode the lowest vibration of the
of the string
and similarly when you have uh a column
of air
in a winds instrument or something
you're you're vibrating that column of
air
and depending on the length of the
column of air you get a definite
frequency of vibration
when you have percussion instruments
it's a little bit more complicated
there's less of a dominant frequency
and there's more of a distribution of
frequencies i think when you have things
like gamalins and so on
you have a much more elaborate
complicated arrangement of frequencies
for the quotes notes but there's a
tremendous tendency one that thinks
about musical instruments to say
we're going to play certain kind of
music on this instrument
and it's specified the music is
specified in terms of notes
and so you want something where there's
a dominant frequency and then some sort
of color around that frequency
so to speak um and i think less has been
done on that that might have been
then there's a question of the actual
structure of the music
and the way that the notes are
uh the the actual um uh you know tune in
the music so to speak
and there all kinds of things have been
done um
there's um a bunch of experiments that
people have done
with for example cellular automata these
very simple rules
that um uh make complicated patterns
that i've studied a lot for the last 40
years or so
actually some of the work that i've done
there has found its way
into uh composers who are doing
uh kind of algorithmic music and we've
developed
things we developed the thing called
wolfram tones back in 2007 which is a
cellular automaton based
uh music generation system that you can
find on the web
the the thing that's tended to happen is
people sometimes say there's going to be
a magic way to make
really good algorithmic music and there
isn't quite
uh cellular automata do a surprisingly
good job
at making small snippets of music you
know 15 seconds 30 seconds maybe
they have a definite sort of logic but
yet their actual behavior is complicated
so they can make kind of a rich
arrangement of sound and so on and when
you render it
with the appropriate scales and the
appropriate instruments and so on
it can sound quite good at least for
maybe 15 seconds or so
after that it's kind of like it's got
one idea and how long can you hammer
that one idea so to speak
now people have also tried doing things
like
pure random walks or things like
fractals and nested patterns
they don't work so well they don't work
as well as cellular automata tend to
work
in more recent times one of the things
that's been common
actually some experiments were done on
this even earlier
take fragments of known pieces of music
and sort of grind them up and
reconstitute them in a in way through
machine learning for example
just get pieces of bach and mozart and
or something
grind them up little pieces kind of
learn the statistics of how those work
and then reconstitute them with
something that is so statistically like
mozart
and see what that produces and one of
the sort of the failure cases there
is well actually that cluster of notes
is something recognizably
from this known mozart piece it hasn't
been very ground up it's really just
like an assembly from things that have
already been done rather than something
where it's learnt the principle
and arranged the notes in a separate way
but there's kind of a
there's a there's a certain uh kind of
idea of of having the structure of music
be able to be produced algorithmically
and as i say cellular automata have done
a pretty good job on that
um and there are no doubt other ideas to
be had along those lines
um there's also the question of kind of
the actual theory of music
and to what extent that can be informed
by these kinds of ideas and how that
affects
kind of what is algorithmically possible
so i mean the the current system of 12
semitones and an octave
that we have is i think dates to
and i think pythagoras already knew
about many of those kinds of things knew
about
the idea that there's sort of a factor
of two difference in frequency
between the middle c and the c right
above middle c in the next octave
and the fact that there's a major fifth
that's a factor of two difference in
frequency
and so on and and these various musical
intervals
that get encoded in the uh
in the positions of notes i mean roughly
the the frequencies of successive the 12
successive semitones
in an octave go up by 12th roots of 2 so
that means
each one is just the 12th root of 2
higher in frequency than the previous
one so when you get through twelve
semitones
that's a factor of two difference in
frequency and there are details
of how you actually tune an instrument
so that you get nice ratios like three
halves
ratio of frequencies for a major fifth
and so on and
you try and get as many of those as
possible and the twelfth root of two
thing doesn't quite line up
with those uh rational simple rational
numbers and you have to tweak it a
little bit
and there are different systems of
tuning that do different kinds of
tweaking and people sometimes experiment
with those
and they produce kind of different
apparent
forms of music and so on there's also
the question of the musical scales which
are the dominant notes that you pick out
to make your music out of
and there are 2048 possible ones given
that you've got those 12 semitones and
you're deciding which semitones will you
include in the scale
um and about 200 get used
traditionally between two and 400 get
used traditionally in kind of
the different musical traditions of the
world so to speak and
there's sort of a question of how can
you tweak that further
but i would say that there there's
there's probably been less done
on kind of the algorithmic side of
of messing around with kind of the
actual structure of the notes and the
and the structure of the sound fonts and
so on there might have been
um i think one of the challenges is that
music that is not like anything you've
heard before
sometimes has a habit of not sounding
very good
um because you know some part of the
story
of lots of these kinds of musical forms
and so on is
it's a little bit what you're used to is
sort of comfortable and then you can
you can sort of uh move a little bit
away from
what you're used to and um
and end up with something that is
creative but if you just sort of
throw out a completely random you know
chunk of sound it's like i don't have
any way to
sort of grab onto that and make my brain
allow that sound to sort of tell a story
to me it just sounds like something
incomprehensible so to speak and uh so i
think that that's some
that's part of that story and of course
there are sounds that we
get familiar with from you know bird
songs and things like this
which then when they are rendered into
things like human music
we don't really know to what extent the
things that make birds think
they're chirping is kind of a good thing
whether that aligns with the reasons we
humans think
that the music we make is a good thing
or whether there's a sort of connection
between what was
one was used to from the natural world
and so on it's rather unclear how that
works
um but those are i think sort of just
going out
uh sort of arbitrarily into the into
musical space
um is some is will tend to lead to
things which are not
sufficiently familiar not sufficiently
anchored
to i think be things that people find
terribly pleasing
let's see uh questions here about um
can you build a cellular automaton for
each sound font
how does one construct a cellular
automaton to map onto functions like
sine
or waveforms well so what we did
in our wolfram tones experiment is
something very simple a cellular
automaton
has a line of cells each one is black or
white
and it evolves in a series of steps
going kind of down
the page what we did was simply to take
that evolution down the page with time
tip it on its side and treat the
the cells that are a certain distance
away from the midline
as being notes a certain distance up on
the musical stave
so we're literally taking the the sort
of black and white squares of the
cellular automaton
and making them into something that
looks just like the early musical
notation from a thousand
a d of just there's a note represented
by this
you know this square in this musical
state
and then what we were doing was to
render that by saying
okay if there's note number two is
rendered as a
b-flat or something with a trumpet or
whatever
um we're mapping this this sort of
specific
arrangement of of positions on this
stave onto particular notes
and particular uh instruments so that
was kind of the approach there now
there's a question could one make
a sound font where the detailed
structure the detailed waveform
came from a cellular automaton and yes
that's a really good question
and um uh a bunch of experiments have
been done actually by for example
students at our summer schools and in
past years and so on doing that
i would say none of the results have
been spectacular but that doesn't mean
one can't get spectacular results
i think one would tend to want to have
something where there is
probably some built-in continuity to the
uh to the waveform uh you could take
something where it's a discrete
sort of cellular automaton output and
then draw a sine curve through that
that might work i don't know um they're
good things to try
not as much of that has been tried as
one might hope
let's see um
well i'm i'm looking at uh
oh gosh so many questions about so many
different things
um
um let me see
there's a question here now maybe i
should
do this one um
there's a comment from wst is science
slowly becoming a meme
considering how strongly support of the
theory has been of natural origin of
covert 19 by the so-called scientific
community
it appears as scientists opinion is more
and more becoming a product
you know the this whole story
of uh sort of the the mixing of science
and politics and public policy and
uh sort of tweaking the public so to
speak
that's happened in the course of this
pandemic has been
oh i i you know it's been very
frustrating to watch let's put it that
way
certain things about what's going on in
this pandemic are sort of obvious to
anybody
who is sort of scientifically oriented
and other things
one might have thought something based
on being scientifically oriented and one
would have been wrong
and i think one of the challenges is
that there's so much that is not
understood about immunology uh to some
extent virology
to a certain extent epidemiology but i
would say
the number one place where there's sort
of a lack of understanding is immunology
which is a very interesting and
important science
but a difficult one that is actually a
very computational kind of area because
it's all about
kind of the interaction of this whole
network
of immune system cells and systems and
so on
and there isn't a great paradigm for
thinking about that
and there are a lot of things which for
somebody like me have been like well i
didn't really know about
t-cell uh based immunity i sort of was
vaguely aware that it was possible
but i thought immunity was associated
with antibodies mostly
and uh i i was aware that autoimmune
diseases had t-cell
components and so on but i hadn't really
internalized the
importance of t-cell immunity in
certain kinds of viral diseases and so
on and that's just one of a whole array
of different things
not at least not properly known to
somebody like me with just sort of a a
basic knowledge of immunology
um i think this whole question about
sort of where did the virus come from
i mean gosh you know my sort of
you know dominant very dominant a priori
assumption was
this was a virus that that was the
result of a lab accident
um and that was my initial you know
absolute assumption and uh you know i i
certainly
went and looked up the papers because i
was curious about this you know produced
by the
the lab in china and so on and yes you
know they've been working on very
similar kinds of viruses
and it's like you know to me that was
sort of an open and shut case
although circumstantial and you know it
got a bit more so
we got a bit more uh kind of in terms of
the human operation of the world when i
started seeing papers get taken down
and things like this that was like
somebody's trying to cover something up
here
so it was you know to me a sort of a
just general scientific common sense it
seemed like that was the dominant
possible theory and then when people
started talking about you know this kind
of intermediate animal and that kind of
intermediate animal it's like
okay you know show the animal and we'll
believe you but otherwise it's just
nonsense um and uh i think that the um
the mechanics by which the scientific
community
or pieces of the scientific community
kind of came in
and sort of certified the idea that oh
it must have been
you know of animal origin and so on was
pretty unfortunate
and um i think that i don't know
what kind of reckoning will come from
that whole thing
but it certainly was not a great example
of kind of um uh free critical thinking
being done and i would say that the the
efforts
on the part of oh i don't know you know
i have to say i will criticize
my friends in the tech industry for
saying you know
this is the science consensus wherever
it may have come from
we're going to lock down and lock out um
every other point of view i think that
was a big mistake
um and uh i think that um you know who
knows
to what extent that will be seen in in
you know sort of the
the the view of history as having been
terrible and shocking and the source of
lots of problems and to what extent it
will be forgotten i don't know
um but i think it was a big mistake um
and i think that
it is a challenging thing because one
will get
both sort of good sensible science and
we will also get
in a situation of of great sort of
public and political
sort of uh foment one will tend to get
all kinds of
crazy wacky things that people start to
believe
but i have to say that my own belief
would be i might not be correct
that sort of allowing all points of view
to be aired
is the most likely way to come up with
something sensible
rather than saying oh oh oh no we
already know this isn't true
let's shut it down um which i just don't
think is the right approach
um i think that that's a uh that has
been
a um uh and i think also there's a great
tendency and it you know it is a
it's a very difficult uh sort of public
policy decision
if you think it's important and it
probably is to get some decent fraction
of the population
to get vaccinated for example then
there are things you kind of have to
tell people you you might think there
are things you have to tell people
to persuade them yes it really is worth
getting this
you know this vaccine even if
you kind of know that it's sort of
scientifically iffy to tell them that
is that the right thing to do is that
sort of good for society
even though it might be bad scientific
ethics what's the right thing to do
my own tendency would be to say you know
just tell people what you know and tell
them what you don't know
and try and be as accurate as possible
in the communication of the science
and in a sense it's sort of laziness
on the part of the science and science
communication to not try and get things
clear enough that you can say
here's what we know is what we don't
know and to communicate that clearly
enough that a decent fraction of people
understand it well enough to be able to
reason in terms of it and to make the
right decisions about uh
or at least the right decisions for what
one hopes and this is where it's again a
challenge
is it the right decisions for them as an
individuals or is it the right decision
for
society more generally based on the
things that uh that
that they know but i i have to say i'm
you know perhaps i just have um
uh a view and you know the very fact
that i'm doing these kinds of live
streams
trying to explain things as best i can
is perhaps a sign that i generally
believe that it's worth explaining
things
and that at least with effort it's
possible to explain
some things that might seem to be very
much in the scientific stratosphere so
to speak
and yes it does take effort i think i
kind of find it
i find it kind of fun and interesting to
put in that effort
but it does take effort and if i were to
sort of replay the pandemic
i would say better science communication
would have been a really good
thing and it didn't help
that people kind of locked in and said
we know this
we definitively know this but they
didn't
and you know i must say that i was wrong
about some things
in my own thinking about
uh sort of what the different
paths of of what would happen would be
and i have to say one of the things that
that affected my
a priori assumptions about what was
going on was that i was pretty sure this
was a
you know a virus that leaked from a lab
and not
a sort of naturally produced virus from
the very beginning
and so while i would have had certain
assumptions about oh
some things are just going to be fine
because we've seen n
pandemics before and this is how they
always work out
when you see a pandemic that was the
result of a
essentially genetically engineered virus
then it's like we don't know what's
going to happen
because this has never happened before
and so some of the things that it's like
you know okay it's just going to work
this way
one couldn't necessarily be sure of that
and so that was
something which certainly for me
affected my sort of a priori assumptions
about things
um
let's see there's a question here from
nick
there was and seemed to still be today a
very discriminating
political approach in the world of
science when somebody tries to present a
different way of approaching something
what are my thoughts on how we can
improve these sort of strict close
science groups to a broader and
more open-minded philosophy you know
one of the things one might hope that
science will be better if it was bigger
but unfortunately that tends to be a
self-defeating thing because
one of the things that tends to happen
is the bigger
some field of science gets the more it
has to have institutional structure
the more it has institutional structure
the more
it tends to want to go in particular
directions
and to be quite resistant you know it's
like well there's funding that's been
set up for doing this and this and this
oh you're doing something different
that's not something that this funding
has been allocated
to sorry can't do that so
it's a it's a funny thing that when
science is smaller and there are fewer
people doing it it can be more agile
it's the same thing with you know groups
of companies and things that
you know you have thousands of people
doing something turning that big
ship is more difficult than turning
something
with a smaller number of people but you
know i think that
this question about what causes there to
be
the possibility of sort of new
approaches new paradigms for thinking
about science
well a couple of things worth saying
they are
almost always the result of one or a
small number of people
just going off in some new direction
they are
very rarely the sort of giant committee
of science
decides to turn in that direction that's
a very rare
phenomenon now the question is how do
you
get the largest number of people to be
these new flowers that are blooming
that are leading to new paradigms and so
on you might say well let's have more
scientists and then there'll be more
possible flowers to bloom
the problem is if you have more
scientists you have more institutional
structure
and those flowers tend to get squashed
out before they can even get started
because there's an institutional
structure that's going in a definite
direction
but it's um the other thing that's
always confusing
is that when you look at the history of
science a hundred years after something
has happened
it always seems to happen
instantaneously you know you don't know
that relativity took
you know decades to get decently
accepted you you kind of
just think oh it was introduced in 1905
um you know it's it was like everybody
said oh yeah that's the way it must work
and all was good didn't happen that way
and
in the things i've been involved in even
some sort of paradigm shifts in science
that i've perhaps been responsible for
um it's been a long grinding complicated
multi-decade process
and there is a certain tendency for that
process to happen
only as a new generation of people
enter a field there's a certain tendency
for it to be the case that people learn
a way of doing things
and that's the way they're going to do
things and that's the way they're going
to do it for the rest of their careers
and it's only when a new generation of
people come in
that it's like well actually we're going
to do something somewhat different and
it's always a complicated
process whether the new settlers
take over the institutional structure of
the old paradigm or they just build
their new institutional structure
whether they build a new field whether
they kind of populate an existing
field and kind of take it over and it's
happened in different ways
in different fields but this question of
how do you get
more sort of innovation in science to
happen it's a challenging question
and i think that part of it
i suspect is is you've got to
actually to some extent bet on people
but that's tough to do in an
institutional structure
it's tough to say oh the us government
is going to put money into this project
because somebody believes in this person
even though the project seems kind of
wacky
based on other things that are sort of
part of the established scientific
wisdom
i mean in my own life i very consciously
set things up so that you know i'm not
asking other people
for support for the projects that i do
you know i have
my own kind of structure and uh you know
the company that
i've run for the last 35 years is sort
of the main vehicle that i have
for sort of having an environment to do
innovative things
in science and technology and that's a
very
kind of conscious effort to build myself
a structure
where i can kind of do whatever whatever
weird project
i sort of want to do that fits within
that structure
and i don't kind of have to say oh i'm
thinking about
trying to figure out the fundamental
theory of physics based on hyper graph
rewriting rules and so on
i don't have to convince some group at
the u.s national science foundation
that that's a thing that should be
funded and that people should give good
reviews to it
which i'm sure they wouldn't i'm sure
they'd say that's a wacky thing how
could it possibly work it's different
from what we already knew
well i you know i have to say back
in the day uh probably what was it 30 40
years ago
i kind of thought and and to some extent
it's true in some areas so i
you know it's like when you think about
scientists you say what did these
scientists actually do for a living
well a reasonable default assumption
based on modern times is
that random scientist that you've heard
of who did some basic science thing
back in the 1800s or whatever i bet that
person was a professor
because that's kind of the generic thing
that scientists saw
is their professors well
i had kind of thought that 40 years ago
or something the generic thing that
innovative scientists would be
is people who run companies and that
the typical scientist would just have a
company and rather interestingly that
has been
in many areas of sort of biomedical
kinds of things
uh computational kinds of things that
has pretty much been the way it's
evolved
that you know your average sort of
person who's doing something innovative
there's a pretty good chance
they have sort of a company wrapped
around the thing they're doing as
opposed to just being a professor
sort of operating within the the
structure
of of sort of the academic system so
you know in a sense that's a mechanism
by which innovative stuff can be done
now of course
you know making a startup company was at
one time an unusual innovative thing
and by the time there's a production
system for making companies that kind of
you know everybody should be an
entrepreneur type thing
then that too ends up having an
institutional structure
where it's like well you get your your
seed round and your series a and your
whatever
and it's all very structured and that
again puts constraints and it says well
you know you want to do a company
that is doing this thing well that
doesn't fit in with this type of venture
capital funding
so you can't do that so any time where
one of these systems gets big
it will tend to get inflexible and so
that isn't giving a great solution
for you know it's kind of saying every
few decades shake it up
and have a different way to think about
the way that innovation
is initiated and i don't have a great
solution for this
and i've also seen places where people
say let's institutionalize
innovation and just put people in place
and have them think for the rest of
their lives that doesn't work out very
well either
you know i think one of the things that
can be complicated is that innovation by
its nature
is a thing that sort of changes over
time
and the mechanisms by which it should be
done presumably have to evolve a bit
because in a sense by one method of
doing it it sort of
it sort of gets stale and stagnates
after a little while
so uh i'm going to need to
wrap this up in a few minutes here um
the uh um
um there's a question here
about um um
[Music]
from aaron sort of thematic did summer
school and incubator programs exist
hundreds of years ago
that's an interesting question i mean
you know there was a time when
the academics you know in the 1200s when
universities started well
obviously there was a pre-history of
universities with things like plato's
academy
but universities in the oxford bologna
paris
tradition that kind of started in the
1200s
and you know you kind of know by looking
at the architecture of some of like the
colleges in oxford for example
with all their medieval walls and
ramparts and so on
that it wasn't clear people were
entirely keen on
those academics uh you know going from
place to place in a rather stateless
kind of way
um and i think uh this
question of sort of who got inducted
into you know became a student there
was very mixed up with the church and
with educating people
uh for theology and so on but i think
this question of
of when um
did a hundred years ago well i know
that like summer schools and things like
physics
had sort of come into existence in maybe
the 1950s or the 1960s
possibly there were things before that
i'm aware of sort of ones whose lineage
goes back to the 1950s 1960s
i would say that um
incubator programs for things like
companies
no absolutely not i mean when i started
my first company in 1981
it was you know you're kind of on your
own there was no
sort of institutionalized this is how to
do entrepreneurial things uh track
and for example you know if you look at
business schools for instance
at the time they were teaching sort of i
think in the general motors kind of
model
of sort of professional management which
was there is a
there is a company it is running this is
how you run it
so to speak rather than this is how to
go from nothing
to having sort of the entrepreneurial
thing started
um i think that that's a phenomenon of
actually probably the last
um oh i mean the the current round of
incubators and accelerators in the tech
industry probably comes from my friend
paul graham
and his um y combinator thing and that
started
in i was in boston in about 2003 2004
something like that i went to some of
its very early get-togethers
at a converted chocolate factory in
cambridge massachusetts
um but
so i i you know this question of how do
you learn to do business
the answer is and how do you learn to
like
start a company i don't think there was
any kind of
sort of organized educational way to do
that
until probably sometime into the
first decade of the 2000s um and maybe
i'm missing and miss
miss remembering something but um when
i was starting doing that in 1981 i just
don't think there was anything like that
i think it was one of these
sort of mysterious areas where you just
learn to do it by doing it so to speak
or you learn to do it in some kind of
apprenticeship mode where
you work for somebody else's company and
then you create your own type thing
which is uh probably a a just
fine mechanism and one that commonly
happens
anyway that's some so i think the answer
is
i at least don't know um
uh oh there's one more question here
this is bad for me but but um from sl do
i think the relationship between the
scientific community
and media business government is
fundamentally different today
or pretty close to what we've seen in
typical above flow in many decades and
centuries in the past
that's an interesting question i think
i'm not sure that it's fundamentally
different i think
in terms of i mean i i'm just sort of
rushing into my my memory are all kinds
of examples from the 1800s
of kind of science meets government like
for example the famous example of
faraday
showing gladstone who was then prime
minister in england
uh some electricity thing
and um you know gladstone asks okay
faraday
you know what's this good for and
faraday's explaining
like you know it's like a newborn baby
it's not uh it's not clear what it's
going to turn into and so on
and apparently gladstone's eventual sort
of question was
well okay but can we tax it you know
what is the relationship you know if
this is going to be a useful thing
how does it mesh with the government is
it something that the government
can kind of control and that's a story
that's been
told and retold over and over again
that's not really anything new
and the kind of the enmeshing of big
progress
in science with military needs and other
government priorities that's a
you know that's a story that's been
being told for a thousand for
a couple of thousand years at least i
think
that um uh when it comes to kind of
the world of business it's uh
the there have been times when academia
has felt itself to be this very
ivory tower kind of thing that was sort
of
at cross purposes and a different
vocation
from kind of the business world and i
certainly
in the early 1980s for example that's
certainly what i saw
was people were like i'm an academic and
i'm proud of it
and i'm going to live in an ivory tower
and i don't want to have anything to do
with that icky business world out there
and business people were like oh they're
these academics and they had their heads
in the clouds and occasionally
we might hire them as a consultant but
it's kind of like they're off
doing their in the clouds type stuff now
obviously there were
continually cross connections and there
were continually companies being started
that had sort of come out of academic
research
and you know people like edison um you
know he was certainly fond of reading
the literature and pulling in professors
and
you know howard hughes the same kind of
thing lots of people sort of pulled in
from academia
to help with essentially industrial
research and so on
and then there were the occasional
scientists like um william thompson
later lord kelvin was much involved that
was in the 1800s
was much involved in for example the
laying of the first transatlantic cable
uh you know he was famously uh the
cables kept on breaking
and so kelvin was there on the ship so
to speak
um eventually with an electrometer kind
of listening for the
the resistivity of the cable to try and
predict when it would you know when they
should slow down
whatever else it was and i think he was
involved in the first successful
uh laying of a transatlantic table that
didn't break
and you know that was one of those
typical investment things of the time
is you know you'll invest in the
transatlantic cable if it gets laid
successfully you're a big winner if it
breaks
somewhere you know on the mid-atlantic
ridge or something then
your toast your investment has uh has
uh is sort of buried under the ocean
type thing
so i think there were certainly
individual people who were
involved in i know kelvin was
did quite well from his uh stake
in whatever company it was that
eventually laid that transatlantic cable
um so yeah i mean i i think
that a lot of these things have been
happening i think that as academia
got bigger in the 1960s and 1970s and so
on
there was a certain sort of you know
separation of vocations that happened
which i think has tended to uh be more
merged in the present day
um although you certainly still see sort
of echoes
of the you know we're academics and we
don't want to have anything to do with
business and
we're business people and those are just
academics and they're doing crazy
useless things
the role of media is interesting
i mean i think that the
newspapers had covered sort of
scientific advances
although seemingly in a very
uh kind of down-to-earth way for a long
time i mean you know
einstein was a big celebrity when he
came to the us
and um but even i remember
uh like the the headline from the new
york times in 1919
when eddington did this expedition to
south africa which
claimed to validate einstein's general
theory of relativity
uh you know the headline in the new york
times was something like
lights askew in the heavens so it's
definitely not
you know not science terminology it's
kind of bringing science terminology
to something that sounded more kind of
for the everyday person and i think the
life and times
of for example science journalism have
been interesting to watch i think the
1980s
may have been the peak of when
particularly in the u.s
science journalism was at its most
vigorous with you know
every significant newspaper having its
own you know science
uh columns and things like this and a
bunch of science magazines getting
started and so on
and that didn't really work out in the
u.s it's it's
worked a little bit more in places like
the uk
you know like new scientist magazine
which i realized recently i have had
an unbroken subscription to new
scientist magazine
for 53 years the only magazine where
i've had such a subscription
it's a it's a magazine that uh you know
it has its it has its ups and downs
and it has some a certain degree of
british humor which
might not be uh which i still find
find entertaining um and uh
but it's been in the us the sort of
science journalism world has not been so
successful
um i don't know exactly why
um and uh so you know that but but now
when it comes to things like the
pandemic and the interaction of media
it's been in my opinion extremely
unimpressive
i mean people in you know the mainstream
large-scale media outlets
you know it's like come on guys you know
did you do no math class
do you really not understand how to
divide these numbers to
you know come to a conclusion are you
really you know
are you really that clueless um i've
been surprised
at how how generally poor the the
coverage of these things has been
particularly when it comes to more
quantitative issues
and it's been surprising to me that
journalists for the most part have not
been prepared to
the mainstream journalists not not
bloggers and people like that
but the mainstream journalists have been
so unprepared to actually
do any rolling up of their sleeves and
like let's try and figure out
what does this actually mean what do
these num you know how do these numbers
actually fit together
there's been a a a kind of a no we can't
do that we're just journalists we're
just reporting what people say type
thing
which has sort of surprised me and i
don't think that would have been the
case
at different times in history but i'm
not sure what um
uh and i have to say i think right now
um i will say and probably i'll offend
people by saying this but i think
uh mainstream science journalism is
quite weak right now
um i think that for example you know i
notice
with our physics project it's you know
it's covered in lots of places
but it's definitely if i say should it
be in this mainstream
you know this place science coverage
that piece of science coverage
it's like well i don't know it's not the
kind of thing these guys are writing
about they're writing about
much more mundane things this is a much
more complicated thing to understand
takes much more effort it's really not
the
the kind of thing and the kinds of
things that are being written about are
much more
uh frankly much more straightforward and
much require much less effort on the
part of the science journalist
you know why it's evolved that way i'm
not really sure i think it's a shame
and perhaps it's related to my previous
complaint so to speak
about people's unwillingness to try to
actually explain science
to people at large and uh in a sense i'm
i'm trying to do my small part here uh
with these live streams
to uh to try and explain some things
that i
know something about in a way that i
hope people
can uh can understand and relate to
and uh you know more people should do
this stuff
anyway unfortunately i have to wrap this
up here
and um as i said my next few weeks are
very dominated by these educational
activities that we have every summer
and um probably this particular
um uh
series about um history of science and
technology
is probably going to be on hiatus for
the next four weeks
although we will be doing a variety of
live streams which may include some
about history of
of science and technology as part of our
summer school and summer camp and um
uh maybe somebody knows that schedule
i'm afraid i don't yet know it
um but uh look forward to
people joining us uh for some of those
um
uh live streams and um
uh i hope um
you found this interesting and um i find
it interesting to try and explain things
and um i look forward to seeing you all
another time
alright bye for now